i would start now i want to welcome
everyone once again to the olympics
research symposium that is starting
today and
so tomorrow
um
and so today we are looking at the
changing role of bioinformatics in
research industry and education
and um
my single honor um this afternoon is to
speak to ross about umis logic training
in africa
and i'm sure a 12 month um findings
reports
all right
so um
once again i wake almost all um on board
to these um bridge
um symposium
my name is adi khalid
are a faculty with leed city university
here in nigeria
and also an associate of the medical
laboratory science council of nigeria
um similarly i'm a mentor and
facilitator
and biotech and incorporate uc usa
um and um i'm privileged to also double
as the program director of the omislogic
africa um program in partnership with
eureka
and so in this session i will be sharing
with us all and the increasing role of
bioinformatics and you know data science
in biological research with the efforts
to present the impact of omics logic
bioinformatics training
in closing the gaps for resource limited
settings and so i'm looking at the 12
month performance report from inception
i'm privileged to quote these this
report with my other members of the team
which i
want to acknowledge mr sonny
all right so simply put
we want to look at the 12 months
performance of these you know of these
um training here in africa
um it is no longer news that the
completion of the woman genome project
in year 2003 has pushed in a new era in
genomics and its application across
scientific feeds so what's interesting
to know today is um how computational
tools are increasingly
being relevant um you know in dealing
with large and complex
biological data sets for requisite uh
analysis and also interpretation to
provide us with you know meaningful
application that uh across several
aspects of human life
endeavor
okay
and so um scientific uh updating methods
and mechanisms you know actually or
sharing uh by the the next generation
sequencing and related technologies you
know together with bioinformatic tools
for computational analysis of captured
biological data sets has been a major
driver of the scientific advancement
that we see in in the research
scientific research and translational
application space today
okay
and though the african continent is
regarded as the cradle of modern humans
and also the african genomes you know
being discovered to contain more genetic
variation than those from any other
continent yet only fraction of these and
genetic diversity among african
individuals has been studied empty dates
okay this is enlarged partly due to the
gaps in capacity in terms of
appropriate expertise and training and
this is besides the primary challenges
of europe which of course is being is
beginning to change especially following
the i'm going 19 pandemic and i'd like
to cite an example for nigeria as an
example
you know pre-covered 19 we we we have i
think just about um two or three
molecular um diagnostic laboratory in
the country but uh i'm i'm i'm proud to
say that you know um into the kovi 19
and you know
t dates we we now have close to 60
molecular laboratories so and these are
some of the silver lining that the kovi
19 actually you know presents so um one
of such gaps however that needs to be
closed is building a capacity that is
needed for bioinformatics and
computational analysis cases to utilize
the huge biological data
that is generated today
okay and
then i like us to look at you know
bioinformatics
as an essential driver as i mentioned
earlier on in need for analysis of
emerging genomic and sequence data and
the completion of human genome projects
you know back in 2003 as elia mentioned
of course um has resulted in a landmark
achievement for bioinformatics as
bioinformatics has become an
indispensable tool for management of the
hugely generated data in modern biology
in medicine and other you know
scientific related fields
however in contrast to other regions of
the world here is these gaps in
resource-limited settings such as africa
and nigeria in particular when it comes
to harnessing the intestine
interdisciplinary and feed of
bioinformatics to attain each full
potential for application in medicine in
population studies in agricultural
science or technology among others so
these stereo source you know the need to
you know to to to
mainstream bioinformatics into most of
our research and studies and
training institutions across the
continent so what are the key drawbacks
to bioinformatics uh you know uh in
africa i'd like to point out one is the
lack of vibrant and dynamic
bioinformatics community
you know according to a published report
by tango etho in 2019 and one drawback
is that many african countries nigeria
inclusive um lastic bioinformatics
community vibrancy and dynamisius you
know compared to other parts of the of
the globe you know
and this is due to limited convening of
these community
populations of bioinformatics and
bioinformaticians
similarly there is also a lack of
bioinformatics expertise
this keyset and training which is why
these are you know symposium we are here
today discussing to look at
bioinformatics in in africa and um i
think there will be a panel section
shortly after now that will
you know look further into that to
discuss how to move forward from here
okay so as a matter of fact just as in
many um other
countries
of the world of of of african continent
bioinformatics is here to reach it full
potential including in nigeria he
reported by far tomorrow at all in 2014
you know alluded to this and also
in their study in 2018 you know
mentioned the fact that
bioinformatics despite some of the you
know advancements and um you know um i
would say
improvement we've seen lately in in the
genome science and sequency um you know
aspect of research there's still a huge
gap when it comes to um capacity um
building for
for for african continents as it's
touches by informatics
all right
so um
i'd like to
at this point
um
i'd like us to look at some critical
questions then that has
rules from several of these works um you
know across across time and space
on the issue of bioinformatics and it's
enrolling in in africa so to to develop
the bioinformatics and uh ensure that
the african continent you know is
actually benefiting from this genomic
revolution there's needs abuse and the
capacity of african scientists um as as
already uh you know argued by
several experts in the genomic science
space and so some of those critical
questions includes how do we ensure okay
we how do we make knowledge of
bioinformatics and big data analysis you
know accessible to everyone including
those that are new to the feed all right
another german question is how do we
ensure a sustainable vibrant and dynamic
bioinformatics community in nigeria and
also in other african countries you know
at large and also another question i'd
like us to look into is how do we bring
the bioinformatics community together
and you know the drive scientific
collaborations and breakthroughs using
these you know these uh levator
computational analysis and skills all
right so that would take me to i mean
look straight off into what we have been
doing in um you know with mixed logic
africa um in terms of bioinformatics
training tools and resources that we
have provided over the course of the
past time 12 months okay these knee gaps
as informed by those questions earlier
raised you know we have identified in
omisologic africa uh eureka and we are
inventively exploring closing those gaps
with the omis logic sets of
bioinformatics and
big data analysis training programs okay
thankfully this is you know brought
brought to be by prime biotech and
computer usa and the focus of which is
to build capacity among students young
professionals researchers and you know
faculties across the african continent
um our postulation at eureka and
mislogic africa is actually that by
increasing you know the advancing um you
know
by increasingly advancing the knowledge
of bioinformatics and its used in
obtaining scientific insights from
design sequence data there will be a
significant group and development of the
bioinformatics community in africa and
also there will be a considerable
implications for
translational science from understanding
gene functions as well as the troll in
biology and medicine for
addressing the challenges that are
peculiar to the population within the
african continent
and so the omis logical by which the
omislogic africa is guided includes
one to provide training in
bioinformatics as well as enabling
independent researcher
research guided by mentors and
peer examples we also are looking at i'm
really working with the goal of
developing a growing
community with a shared passion for
data-driven research and acquisition of
cities in science and likewise um the
third goal is um to enable um students
clinicians faculty of backgrounds to
develop mobile and independent research
using latest technology in life
and
data sciences
and
over the course of the past 12 months we
missed um omisology programs you know
attempts attempted to you know introduce
participants to big data and ngs
bioinformatics training which is
designed for everyone interested to
learn and apply data science key sets on
biological dataset and so the human
logic programs actually boost of
everything in particular needs to get
started and grow in bioinformatics and
big data
analysis space for scientific research
and practice i would want to quickly i
mean show to us some of the
uh you know programs we've conducted in
the past 12 months um in line with our
goal over the course of the last 11 to
12 months we've experimented with our
idea of bringing bioinformatics training
with project and guided learning and
resources to a cross-section of
participanda ranges from beginners and
students many of whom are new to
bioinformatics
to postgraduates researchers and
faculties wanting to also develop skill
sets and research capacity in order to
explore the world of comic sciences
using bioinformatics and big data
analysis knowledge and tools okay and so
some of the high impact training
programs conducted over the course of
the
last one year including bioinformatics
for genomic medicine these are some of
the things we we focused on during that
program outcome bioinformatics helps us
diagnose and treat infectious diseases
we focus on the mineral susceptible um
outbreak and we looked at yes genomic
medicine the era of 19 among other
things and also
we
we also went into some trainings that
included physical mixed logic training
um as well as omisologic meta genomics
and
data science for biologists these are
programs we've organized in the past few
months which i will be sharing the
report you know with us um shortly
equally
we were able to also look at
introduction to bioinformatics for you
know
a cross session of participants which
includes good times students
professionals as well as postgraduates
and
faculties like i mentioned and we also
recently concluded bioinformatics our
computational and biology
you know as part of the program so far
um this is besides um you know some
other programs that we have our
participants you know joining the um the
global report and so i'd like to share
here um some of the results we've seen
okay with umis logic training africa you
know during the past you know
months
while the total registered you know um
interest in omisologic africa programs
to date stands at 2 1298.
um results from our program shoes on
average of about 175 participation in
our free
bioinformatics and webinar all right of
course the the the
the
lowest
attendance was some 56 and we have in
the same session where we had up to 370
participants joining one of our free
webinars all right and um a total of 280
participants you know with 61 percent of
them um average 62 percent being male
and 38 percent female but
participant has you know participated in
our um in in the night cohorts i i
initially mentioned um to ross of the
various programs we have conducted and
in in each cohort we have an average of
about 31 participants and you know
attending i'm i'm glad to also mention
that over the course of these trainings
and we've also given them back to the
community to develop the community and
we've awarded about a total of 20 season
you know um scholarship you know
representing um 9.3 percent of you know
all participants we have over the course
of these
um trainings all right and out of these
we are we are glad to share that it's um
only 50 50
um
you know um
you know percentage across the gender
right both male and female and we've
equally um
you know offered you know two four
scholarship um you know to enable
participants you know have this
knowledge of bioinformatics and thanks
to the prime biotech incorporation and
for for those scholarships and
noteworthy is um like i mentioned 50
gender parity among the scholarship that
has been offered um while 92.8 of total
participants are from nigeria um we've
also seen participants from other
african countries including ghana egypt
sudan
tanzania zimbabwe and republic of benin
okay and i am south africa inclusive
and we've had a lot of interest from the
2298
and known by mentioned earlier on coming
from the you know
northern part of the continent however
there are certain challenges
particularly when it comes to being able
to maybe pay their way into some of
those um trainings and
that is due to some of the economic
policies in those in those countries
however moving forward we are actively
researching into how we can mitigate and
ensure most of those participants from
that part of the continent benefit
richly from our
program
right and so um it is patterning to know
that most of the interest we've been
getting for our programs comes from the
undergraduate students with 53 points
you know um 53.6 percent they're about
indicating um that they are interested
in these in this um omislogic training
in the bioinformatics training however
um what we've discovered is uh most
times there are postgraduate students
and university faculties you know
which represents 22.2 percent on 24.2
um interest respectively uh gets to be
the one that eventually converts to join
the program so meaning we have about 60
75
in total of our cohort um
[Music]
the course of this past 11 month being
post-graduate students
and
this is due to the fact that they find
this i'm training very applicable to
their you know their research and
ongoing studies in their virus
university however we like i mentioned
we have a number of
undergraduate students participating in
these trainings and equally we have
we have faculties as well joining some
of these in fact in each of the
trainings we have um faculties and we
can see the distribution here on the on
the slide apologies for this graph is
two i mean seems quite small all right
so um i'd like to quickly then share
some of the reviews we've gotten from
previous participants um you know you
know participating in our program here
is kingsley better he's a medical
laboratory scientist and just stayed
here in nigeria and he said it's my
first time learning bioinformatics and i
enjoyed the course a lot looking forward
to more opportunities to to learn more
um also we have um
um addition to lua me um who is a
microbiologist i'm from state here in
nigeria and she said everything was new
to me of course many of them and this is
um you know a kitten we are like to
bring here many of the participants are
new to this some of them going through
already i mean having concluded their
bac or even india postgraduate studies
have little no opportunity to be exposed
to bioinformatics you know and you make
sciences generally all right so
she said everything was new to me
however it was easy to understand that
is one key thing that um you know um
omis logic programs you know boost off i
believe to make these things you know
really simple and accessible to our
participants
all right few other reviews um this is
kashim from the northern part of nigeria
saying next generation sequencing was
totally new to me in this course what we
decided to learn by following the
syllabus i got to understand the
principles behind molecular medicine and
the future of
modern medicine as a whole and
last but not the least of course uh many
of these um you know reviews came from a
nigerian perspective like i said 92.8
of our sponsor come from this
from nigeria
so it was a great opportunity to gain an
experience i'm glad to have
i cannot some information that among
that the amount i pay for the program
isn't commensurate too it was
eye-opening period i would be glad to
recommend my friends to experience
continue the good work so um with these
um you know as efforts continues to to
to contribute to building capacity of uh
prospective participants across the
african continent and we like what
we like to also share about our next
training program this year in september
uh on the format and bioinformatics for
medical drug discovery and so for
questions and queries please i would
appreciate you drop us you know and you
reach out to the charts
okay so in conclusion i i like to say
that um just as the generation of
biology data has been yesterday
interpretation of the process data now
presents a challenge to one another okay
because it requires multiple steps
bioinformatics to use our humanity that
is required to generate a final result
from the raw data that are being
generated and so
in conclusion why the green interest in
bioinformatics you know he is growing
across
the continent
only about 10 percent of our
participants that is of the intending
participant rather being able to
actually join the um the training
according to our reports um majority of
the trained participants
sorry majority of the participants would
need to be provided assets you know to
to to be able to
come in and
learn as they actually desired and so
far like we should from our report
majority of the trading partners have
been and postgraduate students or
professionals so far um we are however
convinced that you know with university
partners
on um hands-on mentor driven and
globally proven and training mentors and
resources into the undergraduate
trainings in
universities across uh you know the
continent um you know as the
complementary trainee to whatever they
have in-house for for for their life
sciences students and all others who are
interested there will be a significant
participation from undergraduate
students and that will actually be
representing you know an opportunity to
actually develop the community and have
um you know participating directly
informative skills towards killing the
growth and capacity of
bioinformatics um community within the
african continent
um i would want to stop there now to
welcome questions from us thank you for
listening
all right um
can you hear me please
hello
hello there can you hear me
yeah oh great thank you so um
i would want to
i don't know if mister your face in the
house to anchor the question on
i mean the qa session however i'm
available to take one or two questions
or you know
comments from us
before moving to the next session
there are some questions that are coming
the first one is it is great to hear
from you i have gone through several
articles and research modules
specifically to know how bioinformatics
work is in specifying enzyme characters
and their activities
though it gives a huge platform to solve
almost many cases in modern biology but
still what are the major fields which
are still to be improvised in
bioinformatics and computational biology
to track drug ingredients and metabolic
pathways how industries can implement it
better to make more use of this field
and create more opportunities thank you
please kindly just summarize the last
part of that question so that okay i
think the main question is whether
you can highlight some of the ways
bioinformatics can be used to understand
drug metabolism
and
use that information to develop new
treatments or potentially repurpose
drugs to address pressing medical needs
all right thank you very much yes so um
bioinformatics is really changing the
landscape
of
scientific research generally and that
includes the
biomedical drug and discovery prime
protocol process
so um your question is how
bioinformatics and computational biology
can be used to track ingredients and
metabolic pathways um
yes like i said in fact from recent
you know number of research studies do
outside of the continent they have come
across um you see you know a lot of
efforts going into drug hypocrisy and um
informatics and computational tools is
actually you know key in central to uh
you know making some of those instillico
um you know studies and so uh moving
forward of course um there would be room
for um you know bioinformaticians people
with these um required and requisite
keys um to also you know step up and
then um you know draw up um
various um study projects in the line
and then
in terms of um monitoring the
the entire process of a drug and
development and process so
bioinformatics is really going to play a
key role but like i said i'm pointing
out also from this study you discovered
that most
scientists in the continent you know
lacks these amino capacity as it is uh
do not get me wrong we have noticeable
scientists from the continent who are
doing explode but of course um you know
the
the gap is t i mean the gaps in terms of
um research capacity and
um you know
these key cells is still very much um
you know huge and these are the things
um that
informs the need for building the
community of bioinformaticians across
the across the continent so we look
forward to
you know being able to
you know
part find some of these i'm tracking of
drug ingredients and metabolic pathways
in the process of
development like you said particularly
here on the continent
you know in the near future and
thankfully our platform also provides a
research
opportunity we have a research license
for those who might want to also join
you know in biotech and homeless logic
and to be able to explore these
opportunities